biden's beach house gets a barrier while
the border crisis gets scarier yes we
can't stop the caravan in our direction
but joe gets a fence for home protection
the department of homeland security is
paying more than 450 dollars in taxpayer
money for security fencing around joe's
beach house in delaware yes the same joe
biden who stopped construction of the
wall at the southern border but to be
fair joe's fence is mostly to keep him
from wandering into the neighbor's yard
he keeps giving speeches from behind the
birdbath and it's just annoying
so even biden sees the sense in building
a fence but the optics are worse than an
episode of top chef featuring jeffrey
dahmer
because as joe's fence goes up a new
caravan with 2 000 migrants is plowing
through mexico like brian stelter
through a five-layer wedding cake
[Laughter]
he orders them and he's not even going
to a wedding they've already made their
way past mexican armed forces and are
headed this way in fiscal year 2021 1.7
million migrants crossed the border
illegally according to u.s customs and
border protection and there's no
solution in sight certainly not from
kamala they put her back to work on the
national gender strategy
probably because she's a dame
a sexist would say
thank you
president biden what gives
look look uh
don't tell me about the border i know
the border i've been there
i went there in 2008
and
come on
it's long you can't get a fence on there
it's too long so i i put a fence around
my place everybody else should do the
same thing
it's like a mask all right my fence
protects you
and
half a million dollars that's not bad
for a fence
i mean half a million that's what hunter
gets for one of his paintings
and come on you know they're
they're not that good
emily
it's i mean this is obvious it's such an
obvious comparison to make but i can't
resist it he gets a wall america doesn't
he accepts the logic of a wall
yeah but what else do you expect from
someone who spends our money without
restraint including his salary it
reminds me of when i used to live in
seattle and i would walk my dog by the
lake and homeless camp was erected like
overnight and the neighbor i saw was
building this huge fence around their
house so on top of all the tax dollars
they were paying they had to pay with
their own money offense to make sure
that they were kept safe from these from
everyone in the camp or whatever so he's
acknowledging exactly what he needs and
the tune of all of our money remember
when all of the dhs contracts were just
recently canceled and all of the
diverted funds were going toward
environmental projects i remember that
as if it was yesterday like it was
yesterday i don't know what you're
talking about well basically that all of
our tax dollars going to border
infrastructure that's 1.2 billion and
that doesn't even include that went
going to the wall and now he's spending
500 000 of our tax dollars again to
build his own little fence to keep him
inside the numbers on the show
cat clearly this fence is a hateful
message he's saying i need a barrier
between me and people many of them
likely minorities he could be a racist
he said that
i just said that well
no no i don't think everyone who has a
fence is a racist no but apparently the
wall's racist yeah well look at my point
yeah everybody makes this point you know
i don't like the wall i never wanted the
wall i think that we should just remove
welfare incentives
uh instead so we can save money on a
wall and then of course you know my
husband's more conservative than i am
and he's like well look we got a wall
over here like the small of the
apartment like this wally like that wild
like yeah babe i would be cold
[Laughter]
then i say i'm kind of cold right now
and he says well why don't you put a
sweatshirt on i don't want to put a
sweatshirt on why it's so cold in here
it's cold all the time and then on and
on wow
that's amazing i feel like i was really
there
five months that's the perfect attempt
almost six almost six you're gonna make
it but we've been living in sin since
four months of dating so
but no i don't think it's the perfect
analogy
all right but it was an easy one but it
was and you know you're a busy man i
don't have time to come up with
difficult analogies tyrus this one made
sense it's red meat yeah true it truly
is mean people are not going to like
what i had to do you played to the old
face
i'll give you that you know i gotta be
honest with you man uh the last couple
of times i've i've seen president biden
especially the town hall i just i keep
feeling like i'm in rocky 4 watching
apollo creed just getting killed i just
want to throw in the towel like please
stop man don't talk no more i'm sure if
you cornered him and said hey what's up
with that new fence at your house you'd
be like huh yeah i don't think he knows
what's going on anymore and i'm not
doing it because it's the joke it's
painful to watch in the sea and the
people around him you're probably a
hundred percent why is probably his wife
put a fence in like literally we're
seeing but he has such a great ace up
his sleeve doesn't matter if it's
dementia or whatever medical ailment
he's having which is causing him to be
slow it's not just the gaffes anymore he
has this amazing trump card that he can
play at any time you want to get rid of
me
gad
because the republicans are like
um
section 25 oh no we're not no we're not
no we're not no we're not because of
what the progressive monster behind him
is coming the machine is coming so even
we that's why you're not seeing the
right talk that much
serious talk about trying to get rid of
them because
yeah we we can't the next in line curtis
what would you do with the border
well first off the fence is interesting
uh some in the audience weren't even
birthed at that time but remember ali
north iran of course yeah remember how
he was savaged because he said i need an
electrified fence around my house i am
the target of terrorists right he was
well i look at the wall and i say that's
how terrorists are coming in
as mayor of new york city if the voters
elect me on november 2nd that's my
primary concern because the third time
may be the charm you know they want new
york yeah 1992 they tried then obviously
911 they were successful but they want
to come back whether it's al qaeda isis
or any of those knockoff groups they
want the big apple the terrorists are
coming through that void that's been
created so maybe out of the 2000 who are
marching up to central america through
mexico it could be 10 terrorists in that
group how would we know yeah there's no
vetting process there's no background
checks and we know already terrorists
have been caught of the few that have
been in the catch basin so that is what
our biggest concern have to be if you
were a terrorist right in some hovel in
south yemen
i'll get you my little pretty this will
be the big time what's the best way to
get into the country right across the
border from may he go into america i'd
be a terrible terrorist because i'm so
lazy
no you'd get too nervous i would get too
nervous talk a lot you'd talk about that
yeah i would like i would confess before
the crime takes place
it'd be a scathing email right before
the attack yeah yeah yeah
to whom i'm making one scathing email to
you tyrus and you won't let me go back
again you only took one you little
terrorists
sent us both the scathing
well next if you see something say
something
that's what you do when you see a
scathing email hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else